[Musique]
difficile d'oublier la moitié de la
ville de 65 mille habitants a été
soufflée d'un coup cent ans plus tard
l'explosion d'halifax reste la tragédie
la plus meurtrière de l'histoire du pays
mode à 106 ans est une des rares
survivantes qui pourrait atteindre 3 2
[Musique]
en 1917 c'est la première guerre
mondiale halifax participent aux efforts
de guerre sa base navale fourmies le 6
décembre
le navire norvégien immo qui est halifax
pour se rendre à new york
le bateau doit aller chercher du
matériel de secours destinés aux troupes
belges
le vaisseau français mont blanc lui
arrive en sens inverse
il transporte plus de 2500 tonnes
d'explosif dont du benzène et du tnt à
8h45
limo percute l'avant du mont blanc le
mont blanc prend feu à 9h04 il explose
lors de l'explosion
tous les matériaux explosifs sont
transformés en gaz
vous avez une espèce de bulle de gaz
mais à très haute température et c'est
ça qui en fait explose et ça crée une
non de pression les bâtiments dans un
rayon de près d'un kilomètre de
l'explosion dans le port sont
entièrement détruits la secousse est
ressentie dix minutes plus tard à 200 km
plus loin à l'île-du-prince-édouard son
pinceau à la température on peut
comparer à des explosions nucléaires
comme hiroshima à hiroshima la
température à l'intérieur l'explosion
était lord 300 mille degrés à à 15
mètres de l'explosion et donc
certainement moins fort pour cette
explosion mais comparables l'explosion
fait 2000 morts 9000 blessés et jette
d'un seul coup 25000 personnes à la rue
soit plus d'un tiers de la population
sont en plus tard quoi de mieux qu'une
visite guidée à l'aide d'une application
pour mieux comprendre comment halifax
sont les remises
c'est l'idée de l'artiste visuel barbara
länder
arrivé dans le quartier hydro stone est
ici les maisons ont été construites
juste après l'explosion
elles sont à l'épreuve du feu le
quartier comptaient 325 logements
c'est le premier projet de logement
social au canada ces maisons se sont
transformés avec le temps mais hydro
stone reste un des quartiers des plus
sympathiques daily fx
la tragédie a aussi permis de tisser de
profonds liens avec boston la ville
américaine a rapidement envoyé personnel
médical nourriture et eau pour aider les
victimes
pour exprimer sa reconnaissance la
nouvelle écosse offre chaque année un
sapin de noël au plaisir des enfants il
est installé et illuminée dans le jardin
public boston communes la nouvelle
écosse n'oubliera jamais la générosité
de boston et même si elle n'avait que 6
ans au mode obtenu elle aussi n'oubliera
jamais alors frégates à des beaucoup de
choses ont changé dans cette ville à
l'endroit exact où s'est produite
l'explosion est installée aujourd'hui un
des plus importants chantiers navals du
canada où l'on construit des navires de
guerre ici elisa série radio canada à
halifax